my tongue is on fire
you and me both paris you and me both i
don't even know how i'm gonna taste the
next one oh my god
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by paris hilton
she's a dj philanthropist business and
fashion mogul
her much buzzed about documentary this
is paris currently has more than 20
million views on her youtube channel
and she recently launched a podcast by
the same name check out this is paris
wherever you get your podcasts
paris hilton welcome to the show thank
you
what's your head like going into this
how are you around spicy food
when they told me about the show i was
very nervous
and i was like oh my god i hate spicy
food i can't do this
but then i watch so many episodes and
you just have so many incredible people
on a lot of my friends
everyone looks like they're having a
great time and i've talked to my friends
about you and they said you're super
cool and nice and fun
so i was like you know what i'm just
gonna do it
[Music]
just eat it just dive in
so when diplo was on truth or dab he
called you a sick dj
and in the throes of this pandemic i
think one of the things that people are
looking forward to most
is the return to night life and then i
know from talking to djs in the past
that not every show can be smooth
sailing
have you ever had a set ruined because
of a malfunctioning
foam cannon or somebody spilling a full
drink on the turntable
not a foam cannon thank god but yes
people spilling drinks that's why i
ended up making a rule
that it could not be like that in my
booth because sometimes i would be
playing and then my friends want to come
up and then they're inviting their
friends
and then all of a sudden it's like a
club inside the booth and there's like
20 people
during the middle of a set i've
literally had the music turn off
because one of my friends spilled an
entire vodka soda
inside the entire tractor system and
destroyed it
so um yeah i've experienced that and it
is
so nerve-wracking and so embarrassing
and just the ultimate party foul
as someone who invented getting paid to
party can you give us
one pro tip and then one scam to look
out for when it comes to the art of
ordering bottle service
yes i think a pro tip you know you
definitely need to
come in with people who know someone in
there
or have a hook up somehow so you can get
a table because if you don't have a
table sometimes at these places it could
be a nightmare
and a scam i've seen a lot happen is
there's a lot of these clubs whenever
they see a guy come in who has a lot of
money
they will all of a sudden make it be
like oh this table costs like 200 000
minimum and they'll just make up like
this crazy price and they know that the
guy won't pay because they want to be
cool and be in the club
and also they have like bottle bottle
girls that during that time will come in
and start spilling the champagne on the
floor
while people are drinking so that the
guys have to order more bottles
so there's a lot of scams that go on in
the night lives i've seen it all
i like garlic i like pepperchini i have
a feeling it probably doesn't taste like
either
no i bet you know what mark my words i
bet you love this sauce
okay i'll put a lot on this one right
[Music]
you're right little spicy
actually very spicy now but the
beginning taste is really good
so i once saw you referred to as
america's most underrated businesswoman
despite an empire that includes 19 plus
product lines more than two dozen
fragrances and billions of dollars in
sales as a one-woman branding machine
what's the weirdest product or licensing
pitch that you've ever had to bear the
paris name
there's a big list of them but one they
asked me if i wanted to do my own line
of paris beans
um which i was like i don't know like
beans really don't
like go with my product line like i'm
i'm not into doing
food yet and they showed me like this
mock-up and it was like this pink
can that's with my picture on it holding
beans it was like paris hilton's beans
and then another one i got was just like
really creepy this company wanted to
make
paris hilton sex dolls um
which were like looked exactly like me
and i was like
you know uh this is the last thing i'm
going to want to do
so that is definitely no i can't even
believe they came with me with that
request
it's pretty scary
oh no i support a lot on that spicy
i have my that's hot cup full of milk
dedicated to this great show tie-in
great show tying
mm-hmm so when daniel radcliffe was on
the show he actually talked about an
anti-paparazzi jacket that was made of
this reflective material that if a
photographer took a picture of it
the flash bulb would reflect off the
jacket back into the lens and then
radcliffe would appear
invisible in the image and i actually
saw that it looks like you have a scarf
that does the exact same thing yes
when i was in london i actually met the
designer who created that
and the designer came up to me and he's
like i have the perfect scarf for you
and he took a photo and it literally
reflected back so it's like really cool
like
paparazzi shield i haven't really worn
it
but um thanks for reminding me about it
i'm gonna pull it out one day
and you know i've heard stories about
you like going to disney in full
prosthetics to disguise yourself from
photographers
when you think back what is the story
about outwitting the paps that you're
most proud of
some of my proudest moments had one of
my friends at my house
and i put like a blonde wig on them and
kind of like dress them up how i
am with like you know the juicy couture
track suit with the hood up and the
shades
and then like one of my chihuahuas and
then basically had them run out of my
house like
trying to hide and then all the
paparazzi follow them
i've done that like 50 times so it works
i was listening on your podcast this is
paris and you were talking about the
days where you'd have
50 cars parked outside of your house at
all hours of the night
do you remember at what point that level
of
level of attention started to cross a
line with you i remember
one time i came home and there was
paparazzi out there and they're like
by the way some guy was like looking
through your trash
taking everything with him and he's been
doing this like a couple times and it
was just like creepy that someone was
doing that and then
they would just ring my doorbell and
pretend to be other people and one time
i
walked in my house and my housekeeper at
the time didn't know
because the guy said he was my friend
and he was just sitting in my kitchen
like
waiting for me which was really scary
and then them jumping over the gates it
just it was just
very just like intrusive all the time
[Music]
doing good it's a great conversation so
it's distracting me from my mouth
burning
oh no i've heard a lot on that one too
paris i can't save you from yourself
over here you know
[Music]
so in your documentary this is paris you
say everyone says i'm the original
influencer but sometimes i feel like
i've created a monster
when you look at how the clout economy
has exploded in the social media age
what are the things that make you proud
to be a pioneer in that space
and then what are the things that make
you think maybe it's gotten
way out of control i feel like i've
always been ahead of my time
and doing things first and that makes me
happy and proud that
people can you know build a huge brand
and business that's very lucrative and
support themselves and their family and
i think that's
incredible just to be yourself and have
a talent and a phone and
basically create an entire job and life
out of it
so that part i'm proud of and then the
thing
that bothers me is just i can't even
imagine being like a 13 year old girl
and having these pressures of
having to be perfect and care about
likes and people trolling you and being
mean
and i just feel that anyone out there
should know that
you shouldn't you know base your opinion
of yourself or your self-worth
you know based on the opinion of
strangers i think that's a really
important message for kids to know that
yes social media is fun but you can't
take it so seriously
because otherwise it could make you go
crazy
[Music]
a rooster with fire coming out of its
mouth
oh it's very spicy
but paris hilton battling through brutal
do people make it through all the way
always or to people give up
most everybody gets through because
you're kind of trapped on this show
maybe you feel that you feel like you're
you're trapped
in this room with me you know but let me
know how you're feeling i'm right here
with you i'm right here with you i'm a
support system
i'm not a quitter i know i know i see
the fight i see the fight new pairs
all right paris hilton we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham we're do a deep dive
on our guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so i'll
show you the picture
you just tell us the bigger story do you
have a favorite
formula one memory because uh it seems
like you've been to this grand prix and
monaco at least a couple of times
i've been many many times i've just
always been a tomboy
ever since i was a little girl i've
always just
loved cars and sports and
i don't know just being outdoors i think
it's a lot different than my public
persona because people would assume i'm
not like that at all but uh all of
monaco is just
buzzing everyone's on their balconies
watching screaming
just there for the race the parties are
incredible
every night there it's it's a lot of fun
like i've been to a lot of car races in
my life but
the monaco grand prix is like the most
decadent and
chicest one
oh that aftercase is
brutal oh it's happening
back half brutal
careful around your eyes i i know i was
just thinking that i'm like
i'm usually used to like trying to look
like perfect or like cute during the
interview
and now i'm like making crazy faces
eating
like fried chicken [ __ ] crying
so recently documentaries like this is
paris are framing britney they've
revealed some unsavory realities about
what it's
like to be a super famous woman in
entertainment and the media nowadays is
likely to
uplift the boss lady archetype or
celebrate the bravery that it takes to
show insecurities but i do wonder what
that's actually like
for someone on the inside when you hear
all of this encouragement now or the
apologies that are coming in years later
do you find them to be sincere or
performative
just people reflecting on the mistakes
they've made or things that they've said
and
just realizing that you know like myself
brittany we're all just human beings
and words hurt ever since i got in this
industry
as a teenager i've felt just so much
pain
for a long time just feeling like a
punchline to so many jokes for people
now to finally hear people seeing how
wrong it is and
apologizing is just an amazing feeling i
feel just
grateful and feel that i don't know just
it's an amazing feeling because i'm not
used to feeling it so i'm happy that
people realize that it was just
really messed up that they were doing
that
whether being like publicly humiliated
with people and just being
[ __ ] over by people a lot it's been a
hard journey
maybe i had to go through it in order
for others to not have to go through it
and it's only made me stronger just like
i am so strong i'm here today eating
hot sauce for my first time with you
well speaking of that journey are you
ready to move on here only four more to
go paris and you're doing great
i love it i like the name honey badger
that sounds cute the honey
wish me luck good luck
right
the honey doesn't last long no
like not even is that good
so back in 2006 you released your debut
album paris
500 copies of which were taken by the
street artist banksy who then
doctored the album sleeve changed song
titles
and even put in new music with these
remixes by dj danger mouse
positive or negative what was your
reaction to that when you found that out
i thought i was sick i love banksy i
think he is such a g
i love his art he's like an icon and
when i saw that happen i thought that
was pretty cool that
you know he would have thought to even
get my new album and do something like
that
and i've always been someone who could
laugh at myself so
even when people would make fun of me
before i knew they weren't making fun of
me who i really am they were making fun
of the character that i was playing
i was actually flattered i thought it
was very cool
and i've actually been looking to buy
one so yeah some of them have just gone
on auction like some of them are
like starting to leak out and surface i
know because they're like limited
edition
and i heard they're going for a lot of
money so i don't know i've been looking
for an auction so if you
see any let me know because i want to
buy one all right parasol now are you
ready to move on here
to the next hot sauce this is the bomb
beyond insanity
i'm not sure if any of your friends told
you this is probably the worst of the
bunch
da bomb beyond insanity okay
i feel like this is going to live up to
its name and its label
the picture looks pretty scary too
[Music]
oh my god
this is the worst ever
[Music]
oh my god that has to be the spiciest
thing you've ever eaten in your life by
insane beyond insane
beyond beyond it lives up to the name is
there like little
[Music]
oh my god i have like sorry
the little seed thing was stuck in my
tongue and
[Music]
i get it i get it don't worry i'm i'm
going to move quickly i already
got the hiccups i got the hiccups here
miss one of your lesser known talents
that's come to light
on your youtube channel is your prowess
in the kitchen i have to say
i absolutely love the tutorial on making
sliving lasagna
5 million views at the time of this
interview
what do you have to say to the haters
who say that it's unsanitary to cook in
fingerless leather gloves
my tongue is on fire
you and me both bears you and me both i
don't even know how i'm gonna taste the
next one oh my god
well they're my sliving gloves i always
like to wear gloves and they're always
brand new and or dry cleaned and i'm
always washing my hands
so it's all good and then
you call it your infamous sliving
lasagna what does sliving mean and what
makes this lasagna
infamous it's infamous because i've been
making this lasagna since i was a little
girl
my mom taught me how to make it and
sliving
is my new word which means slaying and
living your best life so i feel like
this lasagna when you eat it is living
you can cook it and eat it
you're just living your best life are
you sliving your best
life right now
slowing the spicy life
still hurts
it looks like a character from like rick
and morty
i know it's spicy it doesn't taste as
brutal as the other one that
it's a lot but we're still we're still
in it
between cameos on zoolander eminem's
just losing video
in the oc where you told seth cohen he
needs to read more thomas pynchon which
one of those is your favorite between
those three
zoolander i love ben stiller he's one of
my favorite
comedic actors and that movie is sick i
just thought the movie was hilarious
and it was so much fun to be on set
shooting it during fashion week in new
york
a lot of great memories and just so many
amazing people in the film as well so i
was proud to be a part of it
i know that you've been taking up
painting during quarantine and even
planned to do an exhibit art basel next
year if your art studio caught on fire
and you could only save the piece of art
that means the most to you which one
would you save
let me just have a little more milk
because i can't even speak right now go
for it go for it
i would save the art piece i'm working
on right now
i am making an nft piece so
that's something that is going to be
very valuable so i definitely
don't want it to burn
[Music]
i can't believe it i'm like in shock
chairs cheers
[Music]
brutal all right paris hilton here we
are at the end of our roller coaster
ride with the wings of death i know that
it's been an
uncomfortable experience but if it's any
consolation we're gonna end here in your
happy place
i've heard you say many times that your
dream career besides the path you've
chosen
was to be a vet and the menagerie of
animals that you've cared for over the
years is on the level of dr
doolittle i know that it's difficult
especially under the circumstances but
as you battle
10 scorching hot chicken wings can you
try to rattle off the names of every dog
you've ever owned
sure sorry i'm like my mouth is like on
fire let me just drink a little milk and
then
i get it i get it
tinker pill
harajuku [ __ ] prince baby bear
prince hilton marilyn monroe
princess paris jr diamondbaby
max and cookie and candy
and nailing the dismount and look at you
paris hilton all she'd had before taco
bell hot sauce here
taking on the wings of death and living
to tell the story and now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you paris hilton
this camera that camera probably just
the one you're looking at let the people
know what you have going on in your life
i was pretty i i've always
you can listen to my new podcast
wherever you get podcasts
and also my documentary this is paris is
on youtube
amazing film check it out and then go to
parishhilton.com
to see everything else that i'm up to
and
thank you guys for watching that was so
much fun and yes that's hot
great job paris great job
that's hot
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans and now that i have your
attention i want to take some time
to talk about the hot ones hot sauce box
this is hot ones delivered
right to your door we give you three
sauces every single month
you're gonna get hot one sauces before
anyone else maybe we'll ask you to weigh
in or vote on future sauces that might
appear on hot ones
there are goodies there are stickers
there are little prizes
it's a lot of fun if you're into hot
sauce or if you're into hot ones
the hot ones hot sauce box it's the way
to go
heatness.com heatness.com to sign up in
order
trust me there are worse ways to spend
30 bucks a month